so here we are at the one-year
anniversary of the Muller investigation
staffed with a singularly most biased
special counsel attorneys in American
history and since then we have witnessed
events unfold which are so unbelievable
so unimaginable you'd have to be wearing
a tinfoil hat or a card-carrying member
of the conspiracy party to even believe
it exists we watched a president claim
he's been wiretapped the Democrats
chuckled but he was right he was right
prosecutors and FBI agents working to
change the course of political history a
shadow government whose agenda is to
maintain their own power and control a
deep state we thought existed only on
the pages of novels alive and well here
in the United States of America we've
watched in real time as text messages
revealed those agents conspiring not
only to interfere with the presidential
election but to then create the basis to
overthrow a sitting president 10 million
dollars and millions of documents later
nothing I repeat nothing has touched the
president in spite of their claims have
Democrats found any evidence of
collusion yes we have I still maintain
that there is evidence of collusion and
I can't go into the particulars but
there is more than circumstantial
evidence now and every time we hear more
is coming the deep state does nothing
but continue to show how deep and dirty
it is the head of the FBI lies to
Congress he even lies about the
statutory elements of a crime because he
wants to protect Hillary Clinton that
same director conducts a laughable
make-believe investigation of his
favorite Hillary with no grand jury no
search warrant no subpoenas where he sat
back and watched as the accused
destroyed evidence deleted emails with
his cohorts in the Department of Justice
hands out immunity deals without ever
requiring that they testify he
Zana rates the target before the
investigation is even over so biased
that he allows the same FBI agents who
exonerate Hillary to create an
investigation against Donald Trump based
on a fake dossier to create the basis
for surveillance of the Trump campaign
paid for by the candidate they wanted to
win the FBI knew that Hillary Clinton
and the DNC paid for that dossier that
had no basis in fact they even tried to
get a friendly judge to take the case
and issue the warrant by trying to set
up a dinner party as a cover that Judge
ended up recusing himself from the
prosecution of Michael Flynn for months
we've watched as the FBI and the DOJ had
denied having any documents they said
there are known the emails on the
Clinton Loretta Lynch tarmac meeting but
there were they lied to us we watched as
members of Congress try again and again
to get documents from the Department of
Justice and the FBI but they won't hand
them over
they Stonewall and there seems to be no
way to get those documents and all the
while the Department of Justice and the
FBI sit back and watch as their
candidate approved the sale of 20% of
our uranium to Russia and then pocket a
hundred and forty five million for their
so-called charity all the while the
Clinton Foundation receives hundreds of
millions of dollars from people doing
business with the US government our
government and when Jeff Sessions
decides to recuse himself rod Rosenstein
a man we have never even heard of
appoints his pal Bob Muller to
investigate our president and this week
we find out the FBI ran a spy operation
actually placing an informant a mole in
the Trump campaign before there were any
legal grounds to do any such thing it
was a classic totalitarian third-world
tactic
this person has as much has been
identified he's engaged in skullduggery
going back to Bush 41 my FBI sources
tell me there would be no reason for him
to even run into a page or a
Papadopoulos and get this he's
disappeared for the last nine months now
I want you to remember that you heard it
here first
any collector their name for an
informant working on a national campaign
must have a sign-off by the Attorney
General here that would be liar Loretta
Lynch Lynch herself would have had to
have approved an informant on that
campaign and if she didn't then the FBI
under James Comey was even more corrupt
going rogue in their attempt to destroy
Donald Trump but what ladies and
gentlemen is unmistakable in all of this
is that the single most dangerous person
to the agenda of President Trump the
Republican Party and ultimately to all
Americans is the Attorney General of the
United States himself Jeff Sessions the
man has done nothing to make anyone
responsible for the blatant corruption
the unmistakable perjury the
in-your-face obstruction of our laws
that we've seen play out every day he
has fought the release of telling
documents that will put an end to this
horrible period in America's political
history documents that would make clear
that the criminals in this attempt to
overthrow an American president
he's even argued that he doesn't want to
release records of Hillary because she's
now a private citizen this man has done
nothing to create confidence that
wrongdoers will be accountable
answerable he's done nothing to create
confidence in the part on the part of
the American people in our system of
justice and with all the power and might
of the Department of Justice behind him
he continues to do nothing
he refuses to take them out in cups the
most powerful prosecutor in the world
the man who holds the scales of justice
in his hands hides behind the coattails
of a-rod Rosenstein a man we've never
even heard of who is in fact behind all
of Jeff Sessions decision who was in
fact running our Department of Justice
the man who has the honor to carry the
prefix United States Attorney General
before his name Jeff Sessions is indeed
the most dangerous man in America